التي تتهم المغاربه بسب الجزائر
والجزائريين
فان من يقومون بها بطريقه غير مسؤوله
يريدون اشعال نار الفتنه بين الشقيقين
ونحن لم ولن نسمح لاي احد بالاساءه الى
اشقائنا وجيراننا
[موسيقى]
المملكه المغربيه تدخل نادي الدول التي
تمتلك اقوى الاسلحه في العالم الدول
الاوروبيه تدخل في المدني نطاق اهداف
المملكه مع اسلحه مرعبه جوا وبرا وبحرا
فيها منظومه مدمره وراجمه مخيفه تطورات
عسكريه مغربيه تخيف الاعداء وتجلب القوه
للمغرب فما هي هذه الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه
التي يمتلكها المغرب ولا تمتلكها اي دوله
عربيه وما هي القوه الخارقه لتلك الاسلحه
تكلمنا سابقا عن ترسانه الجزائر العسكريه
ومن باب العدل دعونا نتحدث عن ترسانه
المغرب العسكري اللهم ابعد عن الشعبين
نارا الفتنه اطلق المغرب خلال السنوات
الاخيره مشروعا ضخما عزز به قدراته
العسكريه وحدث عتاد جيشه ومنذ سنوات قليله
الارضيه يخوض المغرب والجزائر سباقا
مفتوحا نحو التسلح يسعى كل واحد منهما
لتعزيز قدراته العسكريه وتطويرها باسلحه
جديده هذا ما كشفت عنه
سطح الاخيره التي يجريها البلدان حيث لا
يستهدف المغرب فقط شراء العتاد بل انشاء
صناعه حربيه محليه تركز اكثر على احدث
التقنيات في هذا المجال كالطائرات المسيره
والصواريخ الذكيه ليسجل الانفاق العسكري
المغربي مستوى قياسيا جديدا برسم قانون
الماليه الجاري والذي بلغ حدود 17 مليار
دولار فعن اي ميزانيه ضخمه نتحدث التطورات
التي ظل الجيش المغربي يشهدها على مدار
السنوات الماضيه تثير مخاوف عدد من
البلدان المجاوره وعلى راسها الجاره
الاسبانيه التي لا تتوقف عن التحدث عن
اعاده تسليح المغرب بالتكنولوجيا المتقدمه
ليصبح قوه عسكريه بحلول عام 2030 ويزداد
التوجس الاسباني قوه بعد كل صفقه سلاح
توقع عليها المغرب لتحل على الاسبان
كالصاعقه كيف لا والاسبان ما زالوا
يعتقدون ان الحرب القادمه ستكون مع المغرب
بنسبه 87% وذلك بحسب دراسه سابقه للمعهد
الملكي الاسباني للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
اسبانيا ترى تصعد قوه المغرب العسكريه
امام ناظريها في المقابل فان مدريد تعيش
ركودا عسكريا حربيا الجيش المغربي استطاع
ان يضاه الجيوش الغربيه خاصه بعد
الاستثمارات الضخمه في القطاعين البحري
والجوي وخصوصا في القطاع التكنولوجي
المتطور من الجيل الرابع والخامس ناهيك عن
توجه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى
تشييد اكبر قاعده اسلحه من ليلين الرابع
والخامس بالمغرب وهو ما يزعج اسبانيا
وجيشها وايضا الجيوش البرتغاليه
واليونانيه والايطاليه
لننطلق والاسلحه التي يمتلكها المغرب
وبامداد امريكي صيني تركي ومع الاسف
اسرائيلي كذلك حاز الجيش المغربي على
انواع من الاسلحه الخارقه وشديده الفعاليه
هي مارس بعد شد وجذب وافقت واشنطن على
تزويد القوات المسلحه الملكيه بمنظومه هي
مارس الامريكيه المدمره اذ ستجعل المملكه
قوه اقليميه في المنطقه المتوسطيه
بامتلاكها انجع الصواريخ والاسلحه الثقيله
ليصبح المغرب اول دوله افريقيه تحصل على
انظمه الصواريخ المدفعيه عاليه الحركه
هيمارس وهي الصواريخ التي لا تمنحها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الا وفق شروط
خاصه تندرج هيمارس ضمن خانه الانظمه
الصاروخيه عاليه الحركه فهي وحده سلاح
متنقله يمكنها اطلاق صواريخ عده دقيقه
التوجيه في وقت متزامن مزوده بجراب كبير
قادر على حمل صاروخا تكتيكي
يبلغ مداه 300 كيلومتر وتشمل صفقه هذه
المنظومه ايضا 40 صاروخا تكتيكيا
من انظمه قذيفه الصواريخ الموجهه جي ام ال
ار اس بالاضافه الى عتاد اخر ومنظومه
توجيه الكتروني وتمويه ليؤكد المغرب على
قوه عدته وعتاده من الان فصاعدا
حارس سماء المملكه قبل صفقته مارس كانت
واشنطن في عام 2021 زودت الرباط بمنظومه
الدفاع الجوي الشهيره باتريوت وفق ما
اكدته شركه لوك هيد مارتن منظومه باتريوت
للدفاع الصاروخي عباره عن نظام صاروخي ارض
جو المنظومه مصممه للحمايه من الصواريخ
المهاجمه سواء اكانت بالسطيه او كروز
والطائرات واضافه الى المسيرات اذ يقوم
باصابتها وتفجيرها في الهواء قبل بلوغها
اهدافها تستطيع المنظومه اطلاق 16 صاروخا
دفعه واحده يبلغ طول الواحد منها خمسه
امتار ويحمل راسا متفجره تزين 73
اصبحت حارسه لسماء المملكه كما تفعل
بحراصتها للسماء الولايات المتحده وبعض من
دول الناتو في ميزه قويه للمغرب تجعل
اعدائها يفكرون عده مرات قبل الهجوم عليها
[موسيقى]
اسطول المسيرات
عام 2022
عززت المملكه قدرتها العسكريه بالطائره
المسيره الهجوميه الثقيله الصينيه من طراز
لتمكن هذه المسيره الصينيه الرباط من
الحصول على اكبر ترسانه طائره بدون طيار
يو اي في واكثرها تنوعا على الاطلاق في
افريقيا وذلك في سياق تعزيز قدرات سلاح
الجو المغربي فضلا عن امتلاك المغرب لاحدى
اقوى المسيرات في العالم مع انها مسيره
بمقدار تي بي 2 والتي تصنعها شركه بايكر
التركيه اسطول المسيره لم ينتهي بعد ففي
عام 2022 اقتنى المغرب سربا مكونا من 150
طائره مسيره عسكريه اسرائيليه من طرازي
وانضربي وساندربي وذلك بحسب موقع انفودران
المتخصص في اخبار المسيره عبر العالم فاين
ستذهب المملكه بكل هذا الجيش من المسيرات
هناك مسيره
خفيفه الوزن والتي لا يتجاوز طولها الاصبع
الواحد ويمكن وضعها على راحه اليد ليصبح
المغرب ضمن دول قليله في العالم تمتلك
الدبور الاسود الباهضه الثمن التي تساوي
200 الف دولار وهي من الاسلحه التي غلى
ثمنها وخف وزنها تحلق بسرعه عشره امتار في
الثانيه الواحده بمدى الطيران يبلغ 1600
مترا قبل ان تعود الى الجنود الذين
يشغلونها لشحنها من جديد تعمل ليلا او
نهارا وتخترق اصعب الاماكن والتضاريس ما
يجعل المغرب يمتلك اصغر واقوى جاسوس في
العالم
غواصه تايب 222
طيب 212 غواصه المانيه قادره على قطع
مسافات طويله في البحر وتتميز بمنظومه
متطوره للقياده والسيطره واداره النار
ويوجد في الغواصه سته انابيب لقذف
التربيدات وتحمل التربيد الثقيله من النوع
دي ام تو اي 4 كما تستخدم نظام المعاونه
الالكترونيه من النوع اف ال 1800 يورو
وكذلك مزوده بنظام الاجراءات المضاده
لخداع التربيدات المعاديه من
النوعين الذي يتكون من اربع قواذف كل قاذف
يتكون من عشره انابيب اطلاق اجسام خداعيه
مزوده بمصادر صوتيه ومكبره صوت تعمل تحت
الماء وتعمل على ابعاد الطوبيدات المعاديه
عن الغواصه نظام
والذي يعتبر من اقوى انظمه رجم الصواريخ
في العالم هذا النظام عباره عن مجموعه
شاحنات ثمانيه الدفع تحمل كل منها 12
قاذفه صواريخ عيار 300 متر قادرا على
اطلاق مجموعه متعدده من القذائف
الكلاسيكيه والحنقوديه بمدى يصل الى اكثر
من 150 كيلومترا وهامشي خطا لا يتعدى
المتر الواحد ما يجعله من اقوى منظومه
رجيمات الصواريخ بالعالم الجيش المغربي
يؤكد ان هذا السلاح يعد من اقوى اسلحه
الردع فكره سنه القوات المسلحه الملكيه
المغربيه حيث انها بطاريه من ست رجيمات
يمكنها اطلاق 72 صاروخا يصل وزن الواحد
منها 800 كيلو جرام محمله ب 280 كلغ من
المواد المتفجره في 30 ثانيه فقط واعاده
تسليحها في اقل من 30 دقيقه ما يمكن من
تدمير مدينه صغيره في ظرف دقائق تم تصنيف
الجيش المغربي في المرتبه 56 بين اضخم 142
جيجا في العالم حسب ما تشير احصائيات موقع
جلوبال فاير باور الامريكي لعام 2022 لكن
برايكم اي الاسلحه المغربيه هي المخيفه
اكثر
[موسيقى]